noted group of crazy people good at
making lists
a spokesperson for isis claims that the
terror organization aims to blow up the
white house
big ben and the eiffel tower then
conquer paris rome
portugal and spain oddly the
spokesperson for isis noted that
everyone is welcome in this new home
saying there is no difference between an
arab and a non-arab
nor between black and white the
spokesperson also said
here the american fraternizes with the
arab and the african with the european
and the eastern with the western isis
they're tweeting their facebooking
they're telling us the [ __ ] that they're
gonna blow up
uh this is these are an effective group
of people i don't like them very much
but like they're good at the scare
machine i feel like they watch
national lampoon's european vacation
like look kids big band parliament
here are the things we're going to blow
up right right like they have a map from
like one of those 80s movies and they're
just picking things to blow up
everybody like these are just base
threats right like they just say stuff
and yeah no i definitely think they're
going to blow up the white house
i think it's going to happen they've
been able to achieve all their goals so
far
yeah they can't hold on to mosul but i
think they're going to be able to invade
washington dc right i think it's going
to happen
well if we know anything about the
security at the white house the secret
service mostly drunk and not doing a
good job
so there is a chance right that you are
you are correct and uh
it all started with that one guy who
made it all the way into the
white house indoor inside an off-duty
guy and
he reminded me a lot of george bush
because just like george bush he also
made it into the white house without
being elected
and he was drunk i think and then we had
the secret service guys that were drunk
so there was a lot
a lot of drinking happening around do
you find any fear in this kind of stuff
we get it they're doing terrible stuff
i don't want to uh you know undermine
what they're
doing or downplay it um but when they
say this kind of stuff is this just
craziness
i mean it looks like a recruiting
technique right i mean they're going out
to their supporters and saying we're
going after the big stuff
it's not creative yeah right we [ __ ]
get a little fancy with it
right uh no i mean i'm not worried i
think that we've got those things
protected and on lockdown and i think
that
we are a very reactionary society uh we
tend to get all crazy about stuff like
blowing up planes after we've already
blown up planes
yeah so i don't know that we're prepared
for what's coming next because i don't
think we think about what's coming next
but i would imagine that
landmarks in major cities are protected
in some capacity right and isn't the
whole point of what they want to do
is they want to scare us into changing
how we behave isn't that the real threat
the chances that someone from isis is
coming here to behead us or blow up the
white house pretty small yeah all the
terrorists win
exactly that what they can do is get us
to change how we behave change how
we have security in places to start
giving up our rights things like the
patriot act
things like that isn't that what's
really going on i don't agree with you
dave i don't think you've given up
i was just thinking i was talking about
this with a friend while i was getting a
full-body x-ray from an airport worker
and uh i don't think we overreacted
whatsoever the fact that to think that
isis thinks they can scare us by
threatening to blow up the white house
that's like us thinking they can throw
up the world trade center or the
pentagon or something that's never going
to happen
right so by the way thank you for taking
your shoes off before you did the show
we wanted to make sure you were my
pleasure and uh
i'm i'm also facing the east yeah but um
uh
i mean i don't you know the only thing
the only
way i would believe that they would be
able to blow up the white house is if
there was a
uh intelligence briefing paper entitled
isis wants to blow up the white house
and that we ignored
then they would blow up the white house
but only if we ignore the white house
briefing paper yeah well is there
anything so you see what he's doing
there we see what he did yeah
we're gonna blow up there but is there
anything in the eiffel tower i mean it's
a landmark but there's in the eiffel
tower
just tour i think cheese i think it's
filled with cheese
cream cheese yeah i mean bringing that
down doesn't seem like a major
strategic move on their part other than
eiffel tower people are not going to be
happy with you
no i mean it's not it yeah but you're
not you're not taking out any it's a
landmark
right but you're not getting necessarily
getting people in that how confident are
you that the government
is keeping us safe like are you do you
feel kind of like i go we talk about
this all the time i go through nsa
at the airport uh or tsa
too i go through tsa and it's always
like wow these people
like it this seems like an snl skit to
me basically like this doesn't seem like
the type of people that are really
trained to do anything do you guys feel
that the government is keeping us safe
no but i moved from dc to california
so i feel like the farther away i get
from that the better off i am
yeah yoga and kale will save me yeah the
secret service
is turning into an aaa organization i
don't have much faith in the tsa
which i don't know if you've ever been
to an airport trying to get through tsa
yeah but uh there's always two lanes
open six closed
and there's literally well like they say
tsa stands for
thousands standing around and i think
that's what it is yeah pretty much all
right what do you think
is uh is the government's ability to
keep us safe is it real is it all just
an illusion
where do you rank isis on the scare
factor
let us know in the comments right down
below